hey can we get real for a second we've  been friends for 10 years  i know that you don't like to talk about  your life  but a guy with a freaking machete  foreign arm  just chopped our butts in half  [Music]  my father trained me to view the ten  rings greatest weapons  [Music]  [Applause]  how did you find me  i always know where my children are me  against the world i got my back against  the wall  seems like a nice  fella  it's time to show the world  oh i really am  oh hell no i'm not doing this  [Music]  you are a product of all who came before  you  [Music]  [Music]  i must stop him hell yeah  [Music]  that's what i said  oh you can turn it out yeah you can hear  me  marvel studios sean chi and the legend  of the ten reigns in theater september  3rd